all right last night the angle explained
that the current destruction of our
economy our schools even our superpower
status well that is the Democrats actual
intended goal
they've come to despise America our
Traditions Our Heritage our history they
have complete disdain for our
Constitution and believe our founding
was illegitimate
because they believe our Founders are
unabashed racists
now the goal is simple
a leveling of the old America in order
to create something new a new order that
gives them all the money and all the
power
since most people won't voluntarily of
course choose a lower standard of living
and less Freedom the left knows that
this radical change must be forced on
the people
and this is being done through fake
emergencies and phony self-generated
crises
so they cite climate change to justify
the rapid phase out of gas-powered cars
and of course the Banning of gas
appliances and the cancellation of
permit leases for oil drilling
they cite systemic racism to justify
their new Twisted school curricula and
their Dei dictated corporate hiring
practices
and they point to amorphous domestic
threats to justify partnering with
social media Giants to moderate online
content which of course just means
Banning opposing political views
today's Democrats will always have a
reason to take away your money and your
freedom and they found their new model
for what this new America should look
like
now can you guess what it is
go west my friends go west to California
where there's not a lot of dreaming
happening anymore frankly
it's hard to find a state that's more
screwed up than the once Golden State
which of course makes it The Logical
Exemplar for the Screwed Up Democrat
Party
of course California still has its
natural beauty an amazing potential
but the Democrat super majority running
the place has really done a number on it
after they declare themselves a
sanctuary for illegal immigrants they
also became a sanctuary for criminals
freeloaders drug addicts the homeless
and now they're adding something new to
the mix
late last night Governor Gavin Newsom
signed a law that would make California
a safe haven for families who want to
mutilate their children with trans
surgeries and other treatments
now think about this when gas is back up
at six bucks a gallon in California
this is what Gavin newsom's priority is
when homeless are camped out and pretty
much every Municipal Park in the state
this is what their priority is
when crime is skyrocketing up and down
the state
this is what their priority is
and yes this is exactly what the modern
left wants for the rest of America
a government that forces change on the
voters not one that serves the voters
so I want you to keep all of this in
mind when you vote in the midterms
joining me now is Kevin Kiley Republican
California State Rep and Congressional
candidate
um it's great to see you tonight thank
you for joining us
you know I have such great affection for
California I'm a member of the
California bar I lived out there for a
while as a young associate and a law
firm and I've spent a lot of time in
California a lot of family there but is
California the model should it be the
model for the rest of the country
uh well Gavin Newsom sure seems to think
so and uh thanks for having me uh
tonight Laura he said again and again
that California is a model for the
nation and you know what you just said
California has so much going for it I
love California a lot of the people who
are leaving love California too they
just hate the politics and you know you
mentioned how uh you know they use it's
all about sort of control and it
reminded me of what Gavin Newsom said on
April 1st of 2020. this was less than a
month in to the whole uh coven situation
he said that this was an opportunity for
quote a new Progressive Era an
opportunity to reshape the way we do
business and the way we govern he said
that out loud out that this was a chance
to just fast forward this entire
Progressive project which is exactly
what just happened which is why for 170
straight years California had a growing
population but under Gavin Newsom for
the last two for the first time ever our
population has declined yeah and in
California when I was growing up in the
1980s and and 90s California was the
place people wanted to move to
now it's the place that people want to
move from
I mean that Dynamic alone spells spells
Doom for the rest of the country and by
the way Kevin I mentioned that this is
how Newsome spinned his new transgender
Bill he said and I quote we believe that
no one should be prosecuted or
persecuted for getting the care they
need including gender affirming care
parents know what's best for their kids
they should be able to make decisions
around the health of their children
without fear first of all this is a
phony issue second of all
how do they possibly claim to stand for
Parental Choice when it's all about
sidestepping the parents at schools in
California now
oh there is no state in the country that
uh erodes the rights of parents more
than California does but this is just so
typical I mean this bill is just uh
horrible we're actually taking kids away
from their parents but California is the
strategy of politicians like Gavin
Newsom is to promote these just sort of
cartoonishly woke policies as a way to
cover up what's really happening to our
state uh you know when you look at what
has happened to California we lead the
nation in all the wrong ways we have the
highest homeless highest of poverty we
have uh you know out of control crime
the achievement gaps in our schools are
bigger than anywhere in the country uh
and so they try to you know have this
woke cartoonishly Progressive agenda to
take attention away from all of that but
you know people are not fooled we're
seeing people leave the state right now
in record numbers and like you said
California used to be the state where
anyone could get ahead it was the the
full realization of the American dream
and now it's the state that so many
people can't wait to leave behind Kevin
you must be in Congress we support you
100 thank you so much for joining us
Kevin Kiley hey Sean Hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else